[Music]
making a claim for unemployment benefits
is more complicated now than it has been
for the last year and that affects tens
of thousands of people and it is the
topic
of today's la vegas now segment with
eric palacios
there are some big changes coming to
unemployment benefits what can claimants
expect
well uh they can expect to go back to
the way things were before
the pandemic a lot of the requirements
that were
loosened or just done away with are now
back and forth
so if you are getting unemployment
benefits now
you might get a notification regarding
the re-employment services and
eligibility assessment program
now this will be offered not to everyone
but to
a few chosen ones and this means
that you're going to have to meet
with one of their representatives or
counselors
and they will help you and guide you
through the process of finding
work or training you in a different
field that you cannot now
work in you mentioned some of the
requirements were dropped
over the last year or so and one of
those was proving
that one was actively seeking employment
that's changing
yes during the pandemic this requirement
was done away with because
one we knew a lot of people were not
hiring businesses were closing or
downsizing
and two because of fear of the pandemic
not everyone was willing to go out and
talk to people and
meet people uh and so forth but now
starting
last week again if you're going to
collect unemployment
you're going to have to prove that
you're actively looking for work
yeah and these unemployment benefits
have helped a lot of people
get through this difficult period and
it's a little bit nerve-wracking to hear
that
that's going to change you encourage
everyone to do a little research
that's right uh if you're receiving
unemployment benefits you want to make
sure that one
you are actively looking for work that's
one of the requirements
uh keep a detailed log of where you're
going what sites you're using
who you talk to if you've had any
interviews all that is what you're going
to need to prove that you are
actively looking up for work on top of
that it's a good idea to go to
detr.nb.gov
that's the website for the department of
unemployment
and you can stay on top of what's
required what benefits you're entitled
to
and just to make sure that you keep your
eligibility as long as you can until you
find work
eric always great information appreciate
it thanks for having me we'll see you
soon
for more information you can give eric
palacios and associates a call there's
the number seven zero two four four four
seven seven seven seven or you can visit
their website at ericpalacioslaw.com
las vegas now will be